Kirstie Alley's final TV role was an
unexpected one but that was all part of
her plan here's how she surprised the
world one last time in a bulky pink
Mammoth costume
Kirstie Alley kept working almost right
up until her sudden surprising death at
age 71. some of the actresses late
career projects had been television
series including scream queens and
flaked and movies such as accidental
love and you can't take my daughter her
final television appearance though came
in April 2022 on The Masked Singer she
did make one public appearance on camera
after that but not on TV roughly three
months before her death on December 5th
2022 Ali shot a promo letting fans know
she was joining The Cameo app where fans
can pay to request personalized video
messages she deployed her classic
deadpan humor showing she was the same
performer she'd always been giving
examples of possible messages people
could send hi I love you or
um you know Merry Christmas or I want a
divorce whatever you need I'll deliver
Ali showed that same willingness to
please as baby mammoth on the seventh
season of The Masked Singer she was
introduced in her costume singing
walking after midnight by Patsy Cline
she later sang the Shoop Shoop song it's
in his Kiss by Cher and me too by Meghan
Trainor Ali was eliminated in The
Season's eighth week the judges had
difficulty recognizing who was behind
the mask earlier in the season the only
one to correctly guess her was Jenny
McCarthy Ali said her prior relationship
with McCarthy made her think she would
correctly guess who she was in her exit
interview Ali described the difficulties
of wearing her baby mammoth costume
which included a giant cartoonish pink
head the cheers star joked that she may
have chosen a different costume if she
could go back in time describing the
disguise as constricting and nearly
blinding she advised future performers
when you're choosing your costumes go
skimpy according to deadline the
producers of The Masked Singer announced
after her passing that the show would
pay respect to the actress with a
tribute card airing during its special
holiday episode while Ali kept plenty
busy with work toward the end of her
life she explained after her Masked
Singer appearance that the show was
something new for her a shake-up to her
life and career about 10 years ago I
realized I always had to keep mixing my
career mixing my life up or it was going
to get really mundane she said she also
did the show to please a specific
audience her grandchildren she told Los
Angeles Times I have grandchildren and
they're really young so they are going
to think this is good the actress never
held back when gushing about her
grandchildren in public including in
2017 when she couldn't say enough good
things about spending the holidays with
her grandson Ali told people when I got
up in the morning as soon as that baby
was up I was holding that baby traipsing
around with him and showing him all the
Christmas lights and singing to him
foreign